board he has more chances to trick
magnus and of course we mentioned the
knight and queen worked very well
together um saying that it's a safe pawn
isn't it really now so nothing to worry
about it's what we call the two result
game right yeah i guess so magnus
playing for the win but
even if liam defends perfectly it's only
going to be a draw i think it's going to
take a miracle for liam to win this game
that being said he is creating some
sneaky threats uh using that black
knight going towards the white king
threatening some checks
and the white king running away to
safety preempting any checks maybe i'm
not sure about that king running away to
safety no i was wondering what you do
against this move
wow
i mean i missed that one as well i mean
knight a2 and look at magnus he's
shaking his head a bit
is he is did he just miss oh my words
look at
oh
it
and magnus's mouse slipped he just gave
away his queen and he's lost
incredible wow oh this is so dramatic
what just happened a huge mouse slip
blunder first and then a mouse slip it
just fell apart for magnus in the space
of 30 seconds yeah